Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga, der Männer wollen uns heute auseinandersetzen mit Fortuna, Düsseldorf, Arminia Bielefeld und Hansa Rostock. Und das alles passiert hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 258. Ich grüße euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Hier ist der Kurzpass und wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Liga. Und dazu begrüße ich euch ganz herzlich. Mein Name ist Max-Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Im Grunde gibt es eigentlich fast allen Fußball-Content nur noch dort, nicht mehr auf Twitter. Und ich freue mich, dass ich jetzt drei Gäste hier habe. Zum einen die Stimme der 2. Liga, Eva-Lotte Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Pod. Eigentlich muss ich sie gar nicht vorstellen. Nur pro forma, sie heißt auch Eva Bohle auf Twitter. Schön, dass du hier bist, liebe Eva.
Ich wollte gerade schon sagen, man hat dann das nächste Mal Geburtstag, aber das weiß ich ja eigentlich. Das wäre ein bisschen spät, wenn er da das nächste Mal gewinnt.
Du bist also schuld.
Ja, das nehme ich gerne auf mich, aber ich hatte gehofft, dass vielleicht auch noch der eine oder andere Hansa-Fan irgendwann mal am Spieltag Geburtstag hat und dann auch ein ähnliches Geschenk bekommt. Hat leider nicht geklappt. Ja, und als wir das letzte Mal zusammensaßen – Max weiß gar nicht mehr, wie lange das her ist, so fünf Wochen wahrscheinlich ungefähr – da hatte ich ja auch gesagt, Uwe Koschinert ist ein Macher und dem traue ich eigentlich zu, dass er Bielefeld unten rausführt. Dafür haben sie bis jetzt dann doch recht wenig Punkte geholt. Und ich hatte auch gesagt, Hansa hat mit zwei Toren vier Punkte geholt. Und ich hoffe, dass wir auf Platz 14 stehen damals, nicht weiter abrutschen, damit wir eben in der kommenden Saison mit einem Auswärtsspiel im DFB-Pokal starten, was gleichbedeutend mit einem wahrscheinlich relativ sicheren Klassenhalt wäre. Ja, ist jetzt nicht so gekommen, weil – ihr habt das mehrfach schon angesprochen – Hansa einfach keine Tore schießt. Oder jetzt sind wir mal wieder ein bisschen dazu übergegangen, aber zwei gegen Düsseldorf nützen dir nicht so sonderlich viel, wenn du fünf bekommst. Zwei gegen Holstein Kiel nützen dir auch nicht so sonderlich viel, wenn du drei bekommst. Ja, und so sind wir unten reingerutscht. Und mit jedem Spieltag wird der Abstand gefühlt ein kleines bisschen größer gefühlt, deshalb weil die anderen – ihr habt das jetzt schon relativ ausführlich besprochen – ja auch nicht so richtig von der Stelle kommen an manchen Standorten. Ja, und deswegen gab es dann eben auch vor ein paar Wochen nochmal den zweiten Trainerwechsel diese Saison. Der erste war von Jens Härtel zu Patrick Glöckner, der zweite war jetzt zu Alois Schwarz. Aber die Ergebnisse lassen weiter auf sich warten leider.
Wobei man den Vorteil hat, dass man von allen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, also nur Eintracht Braunschweig hat so ein halbwegs vergleichbares Programm, man spielt noch gegen sehr viele direkte Konkurrenten. Also ich weiß nicht, ob man 4. jetzt schon dazuzählen darf, würde vielleicht jemand protestieren, auch lautern definitiv nicht. Aber dann geht's los. Anfang Mai Heimspiel gegen Jan Regensburg, aktuell Tabellenplatz 16. Dann Auswärtsspiel in Sandhausen, aktuell Tabellenplatz 18. Dann Auswärtsspiel beim 1. FC Nürnberg, aktuell Platz 14. Und am Ende der Saison ein Heimspiel zu Hause gegen genau jene Braunschweiger. Also es sind zwar nicht mehr viele Spiele, aber immerhin hat Schwarz die Möglichkeit, das vielleicht in diesen direkten Duellen zu richten.
Naja, das ist natürlich so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, an die man sich klammert. Aber meine Einschätzung ist da, wenn man jetzt ja mit dieser Serie, mit so vielen nicht gewonnenen oder verlorenen Spielen in diese vier Spiele geht, dann wird man die auch nicht gewinnen. So, also außer gegen Jan Regensburg vielleicht, weil gegen die gewinnen wir immer. Aber das würde ja jetzt nicht reichen, am Ende wahrscheinlich nicht mal reichen, um den Relegationsplatz zu bekommen. Gegen Sandhausen haben wir uns jetzt die meiste Zeit schwergetan in den Spielen in der 2. Bundesliga. Also ja, da würde ich mich jetzt nicht drauf verlassen. Aber so richtig, einen richtigen Hoffnungsschimmer, wie wir vorher schon in den Flow kommen, habe ich aktuell auch nicht, ehrlicherweise.
Okay, da musst du mir jetzt aber nochmal erklären. Olli, was ist denn da eigentlich passiert? Also die Hinrunde Hansa Rostock auf Tabellenplatz 9. Auch da hat man schon wenige Tore erzielt, aber das wussten alle. 17 Tore erzielt, 23 kassiert. Daraus hat man 21 Punkte gemacht. Also man hat es immerhin geschafft, eben da mit wenig viel zu erreichen. Und jetzt dann eben die angesprochenen 4 Punkte, die man bisher gesammelt hat. Und deswegen steht man jetzt bei 25 und auf dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz. Wie ist das zu erklären?
Ich glaube, das ist eine Reihe von Gründen, die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielen. Dann müssen wir auch nochmal einen Schritt zurückgehen in die letzte Saison. Das war ja dann unser erstes Jahr in der 2. Bundesliga nach sehr vielen Jahren. Neun Jahren dritte Liga, glaube ich. Und ja, dann ist man zur Halbserie, stand man, glaube ich, knapp über dem Strich. Hatte auch bedingt durch gute Pokalspiele so eine gewisse Euphorie, die dann einige Punkte geholt haben. War dann aber vor Weihnachten so ein bisschen in so ein Trott geraten, dass man dann nicht mehr so richtig gewonnen hat. Und dann ging man ins Jahr 2022. Und ja, dann hat es irgendwie auch noch ein bisschen gedauert. Und dann haben wir Mitte Februar, also auch wieder kurz vor meinem Geburtstag, haben wir 4 zu 1 bei Dynamo Dresden gewonnen. So, und das war, glaube ich, so ein bisschen der Startpunkt. Dann gab es noch einen Unentschieden gegen Darmstadt, Niederlage, gegen Nürnberg. Und dann kam die Serie, über die wir heute in Rostock, glaube ich, immer noch alle sprechen. Da gab es einen 4 zu 3-Sieg auf Schalke und danach folgend drei Siege gegen Kiel, gegen Sandhausen und zu Hause gegen St. Pauli. Damals noch Tabellenführer, das war natürlich in Rostock dann eine relativ große Freude, diesen zu stürzen und dann auch nicht mehr auf die Beine kommen zu sehen für den Rest der Saison, während man selbst sich mit diesem Spiel faktisch gerettet hatte. Ja, und dann gab es Diskussionen um den Trainer Jens Herthel, die ich aus der Ferne nur so bedingt nachvollziehen könnte. Also bei Jens Herthel ist es üblich, dass er seine Verträge immer nur um ein Jahr verlängert. Insofern hat man dann relativ regelmäßig die Diskussion, ob wieder verlängert werden sollte und das hat sich dann irgendwie hingezogen. Das haben alle nicht verstanden, weil Jens Herthel war der Trainer nach der Wende, der Hansa am längsten betreut hat. Frank Pagelsdorf war zweimal da. Der ist insgesamt länger da gewesen, aber am Stück war Jens Herthel am längsten da. Er hat uns mit kontinuierlicher Arbeit aus der dritten Liga rausgebracht, hat uns souverän in der zweiten Liga gehalten. Dann gab es ein paar Aussagen vom Sportdirektor Martin Piekenhagen, die mich darauf schließen lassen, dass man so ein bisschen mehr wollte. Dass er so etwas gesagt hat wie, wir wollen uns natürlich in der zweiten Bundesliga etablieren, wir wollen aber auch spielerisch vorankommen. Da müssen wir eben gucken, ob das der richtige Trainer ist oder welchen Trainer wir dafür brauchen. So sinngemäß war die Aussage. Was für mich so ein bisschen darauf hindeutet, okay, man war sich relativ sicher, dass man den Kader zusammenstellen kann, der auf jeden Fall den Klassenerhalt schafft. Aber dass man vielleicht eben schon noch einen Tick höher guckt, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Platz 11, 10, 9. Und jede Platzierung in der zweiten Liga heißt ja dann auch jede Menge mehr Geld, die man dann im darauffolgenden Jahr durch die Fernsehennahmen bekommt. Und ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen das Ziel. Naja, man hat auf jeden Fall dann mit vielen Leistungsträgern aus der letzten Saison verlängert. Und das war jetzt in Rostock so ein bisschen neues Gefühl, weil du vorher so diesen Drittligar-Rhythmus hattest, alle Spieler unterschreiben für zwei Jahre. Und die Guten sind da wieder weg, die nicht so guten, die möchtest du selber tauschen. Und dass du jetzt das erste Mal das Gefühl hattest, okay, hier hast du jetzt einen Mannschaftskern, der vielleicht auch ein bisschen länger zusammen bleibt, punktuell verstärkt wird und dann eben, ja, sich peu à peu in dieser zweiten Bundesliga etabliert. Naja, dann war der Sommer, dann haben wir relativ überraschend Hanno Behrens verloren, der war letztes Jahr schon eine wichtige Stütze, fünf Tore gemacht, sechs Assists. Und Hansa war immer dann gut, wenn Behrens fit war. Zwischendurch war mal eine Phase, da hat er ein paar Spiele gefehlt. Das war die Phase, wo Hansa dann auch kaum gepunktet hat. Als er wieder da war, lief es plötzlich. Ja, dann hatten wir mit John Ferhug, haben wir immer noch, aber letzte Saison einen Stürmer, der 17 Tore gemacht hat, der aktuell eins hat. Und ja, da hat man sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen von blenden lassen oder ein bisschen darauf vertraut, dass man diese Quote wiederbekommt. So hat dann mit Lukas Hinterseher noch einen Stürmer dazu geholt, der aus meiner Sicht eins zu eins der identische Spielertyp ist. Der jetzt aber auch noch nicht so sonderlich viel Einsatzzeit hatte, hat immerhin aber schon zwei Tore gemacht. Naja, dann die höheren Ziele habe ich angesprochen. Aber wenn man jetzt mal so stand heute drauf guckt, gab es eigentlich kaum sinnvolle Transfers im Sommer. Wir haben – Moment – zwei Ersatztorhüter neu geholt. Relativ spät Rick van Drongelen bekommen, den würde ich als Verstärkung bezeichnen. Und dann muss ich schon ganz schön scrollen. Dennis Dressel ist noch dazu gekommen, der hat auch oft gespielt, der war sicherlich auch eine sinnvolle Ergänzung. Und Kai Pröger von Paderborn, der in der Hinrunde einige Tore gemacht hat, in der Rückrunde auch noch keins. Und das ist tatsächlich schon an den Spielern, wo ich sage, okay, die haben uns in irgendeiner Form verstärkt oder zumindest das Niveau, was wir vorher hatten, gehalten. Alle anderen sind leider Mitläufer, im besten Fall, oder im noch schlechteren Fall Ergänzungsspieler. So und dann beispielhaft sicherlich Sebastian Till, der mit viel Vorschusslorbeeren kam, der in Moldawien gespielt hatte, da auch Champions League gespielt hatte gegen Al-Madrid, mal gewonnen hat mit Sheriff Tiraspol. Und wo alle gedacht haben, wow, das ist ein Knaller. Und das ist vielleicht auch so derjenige der Hanno Behrens, der dann nach Indonesien gewechselt ist, zu Saisonbeginn ersetzen kann. Und das konnte er leider überhaupt nicht erfüllen. Warum weiß ich auch gar nicht so genau. Am Anfang der Saison war er verletzt und irgendwie ist er seitdem gar nicht mehr richtig reingekommen und war zuletzt meistens nicht mal im Kader, was ich persönlich irgendwie sehr schade finde. Ja, dann hast du in der Abwehr musstest du relativ oft umbauen. Hast du auch oft gewechselt zwischen 3er-5er und einer Viererkette. Hattest da wirklich verschiedene Formationen. Das hatte Verletzungsgründe, das hatte Formgründe. Aber insgesamt ist die Hansa-Abwehr nicht an diese Stärke herangekommen, die sie über die Jahre davor ausgezeichnet hat. Und das ist jetzt gerade in der Rückrunde das Problem. Naja, dann hast du die Winterpause einigermaßen verschenkt. Also im November, zwei Spieltage vor Ende der Hinrunde, wurde Jens Hertel dann beurlaubt. Und da muss ich auch sagen, das war irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl, weil Jens Hertel, den kannte ich ja schon aus Magdeburg, hatte da schon lange mit ihm zusammengearbeitet. So, dann ist er zu meinem Verein gewechselt und hat diesen Move, den er in Magdeburg ja schon gemacht hat, einfach wiederholt. Und ja, dass ich dann schon auch so irgendwie mal als Fan eben eine enge Bindung zu einem Trainer haben kann, die hatte ich zu Jens Hertel und würde sagen, das ist mein Trainer, also dem würde ich auch überall hinfolgen. Und dieses Gefühl hatten glaube ich viele Hansa-Fans und trotzdem ja auch befeuert durch diese Diskussion im Sommer. Und nachdem, wie die Spiele so in der Hinrunde liefen, hatte ich und hatten glaube ich viele schon das Gefühl, das geht irgendwie zu Ende. Aber man stand, glaube ich, bei der Entlassung auf Platz 12, hat aber punktemäßig ein bisschen überperformt, also gerade in den ersten Saisonspielen beim HSV gewonnen, gegen St. Pauli gewonnen, gegen Amina Bielefeld gewonnen, die ja damals noch als Absteiger aus der Bundesliga ein bisschen höher eingeschätzt wurden als das, was jetzt stand heute rausgekommen ist. Also aus den ersten fünf Spielen drei Siege. Das war ziemlich gut. Und danach waren relativ oft Spiele dabei. Ja, wenn Hansa in Rückstand geraten ist, hätte man das Spiel eigentlich auch abpfeifen können. Aber es gab immer noch so einen Sieg, dass man eben nicht unten gerutscht ist, dass man irgendwie den Abstand gehalten hat. Oder auch als Glöckner übernommen hatte zwei Spiele vor Ende, gab es einen Unentschieden gegen Nürnberg, gab es einen Sieg gegen Braunschweig. Und damit war man ja erstmal wieder im sicheren Hafen und konnte entspannt in die Winterpause gehen. Ja, dort wurde es dann verpasst, neue Spieler zu holen. Und das ist sicherlich ein Punkt, der Martin Piekenhagen auch sehr stark angelastet wurde. Und ich kann es einerseits verstehen, dass es es nicht gemacht hat, weil auch schon 30 Spieler im Kader sind. Und man ja, gerade nach der Rückrunde in der letzten Saison, schon auch, na ja, zumindest hoffen, vielleicht erwarten konnte, dass der Großteil der Spieler, die bewiesen hatten, dass wir absolut das Zweigliga-Format haben, das auch wieder auf den Platz bringen werden und entsprechende Ergebnisse einfahren werden. Das ist leider nicht passiert. So, dann musste Glöckner gehen. Und ja, dann kam eben Alois Schwarz. Und eine Sache ist mir jetzt gerade nebenbei noch aufgefallen, die ich so nachgeguckt hatte. Ja, keine Mannschaft außer Heidenheim, die da irgendwie eine krasse Abweichung haben, hat so eine Differenz zwischen Expected Goals und tatsächlichen Goals. Also, Hansa hat 30, 3 erwartete Tore, hat aber nur 23 geschossen. Also, ich sag mal, mit der Ausbeute, die wir vorhin gerade thematisiert hatten, hätten wir mit sieben Toren mehr, wahrscheinlich 15 Punkte mehr geholt. Würde ich jetzt mal so mich weit aus dem Fenster lehnen. Aber ja, und das zeigt eben auch, okay, es fehlt jetzt nicht nur an den Chancen, wobei es das oft auch ist, sondern es sind wirklich auch die, die man hart lässt man liegen. Und exemplarisch fällt mir da eben eine Szene aus dem Rückspiel gegen St. Pauli ein. St. Pauli schon über weite Strecken der ersten Hälfte dominiert. Zum Schluss Hansa ein, zwei Chancen gehabt. Und dann gab es in der zweiten Halbzeit eine Szene. Ball wird rausgespielt auf die rechte Seite. Moritz Schröter legt in die Mitte. John Verhoog völlig frei. Das war im Prinzip ein Elfmeter. Und der Torwart von St. Pauli schafft es irgendwie noch, den Ball zu halten. Und das war aus 100 Metern Entfernung, war das ein sicheres Tor. Und wo ich sage, letzte Saison hätte Johnny, wie wir ihn nennen, den auf jeden Fall reingemacht. Diese Saison machte den eben nicht. Und solche Situationen finden sich relativ oft. Ja, und dann wird es eben eng. Und deswegen steht der FC Hansa, da wo er steht.
Und was hat Ale Schwarz jetzt verändert? Und glaubst du, das kann noch reichen?
Da kann ich jetzt gar nicht so viel sagen. Also in der Abwehrformation wechselt er auch hin und her, wie ich es gesehen habe. Und zum Beispiel jetzt am Wochenende hat Magdeburg parallel gespielt und dann betreue ich ja noch den Halleschen FC, die haben auch noch parallel gespielt. Deswegen habe ich ehrlicherweise das Hansa-Spiel zur Halbzeit ausgemacht, weil Hansa war einer weniger. Und ich habe vermutet, dass es 0 zu 2 oder 0 zu 3 ausgehen wird. Und dann dachte ich, naja, dann nutze ich die Zeit lieber für meine Arbeitsmannschaften. Es kam leider genauso. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was mir negativ auffällt, ist, dass wir jetzt noch schlechter in der Abwehr sind. Also exemplarisch fällt mir das Spiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf ein. Das hatte ich mal so ein paar Minuten laufen lassen. Also ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich auch wirklich momentan oft schnell die Lust verliere, mir die Spiele anzugucken, wenn ich nicht selber da bin. Und dann war ich im Urlaub und dann habe ich immer so gedacht, du schaust mal rein und dann fallen in der Phase gerade irgendwie zwei oder drei Tore für den Gegner und dann mache ich wieder aus. So, aber gegen Düsseldorf waren das wirklich katastrophale Fehler und dann war jetzt das Spiel gegen Holstein-Kiel. Hansa führte relativ lange in der ersten Halbzeit 1-0 und kriegt dann kurz vor der Pause zwei Gegentore, weil sie sich wirklich da bei guter Strafraumbesetzung mit fünf, sechs Leuten im eigenen Strafraum da auf billigste Weise ausspielen lassen und dann die Gegentore bekommen. Also was ich mir eigentlich wirklich nur mit absoluter Verunsicherung erklären kann, dass du eben sagst, ja, so wie die ganze Rückrunde bis jetzt gelaufen ist, so wie da ein bisschen Gegenwind kommt, dann knickst du eben ein. Und deswegen ist mir jetzt tatsächlich noch nichts aufgefallen, was unter Alois Schwarz besser geworden ist.
Gut, man hat ja noch die direkten Duelle und dann, und noch gibt es ja auch die Tuchfühlung nach oben. Also die schlechte Rückrunde hat ja nicht verhindert, dass man absolut chancenlos wäre. Es sind zwei Punkte auf den Relegationsplatz, vier Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Jetzt ist Rostock wahrscheinlich den Hörern und Hörern auch mal anders über den Weg gelaufen. Und das sind jetzt dann nicht sportliche Themen, die man hat. Also zum einen hat man immer wieder zum Teil offen Rechtsradikale oder Nazis, die man im Rostocker Fanumfeld sieht. Gerade natürlich auf St. Pauli wurde das auch sehr gut dokumentiert und war zu erkennen. Gleichzeitig gab es eine Image-Kampagne vom Verein. Ich glaube, das ist das, was vielen Hörern und Hörern über den Weg gelaufen ist, indem Spieler natürlich im Auftrag des Vereins sich dazu geäußert haben, keine Politik im Stadion ausüben zu wollen. Um es jetzt mal dezent zu formulieren, wirkt unglücklich auf mich. Wie schaust du auf das?
Ja, wenn wir es positiv formulieren wollen. Also die anderen Videos, das muss man vielleicht noch dazu sagen, waren – ich kriege es jetzt nicht mehr genau zusammen – keine Becherwürfe, keine Gewalt. Und dieses Thema Politik war, glaube ich, kein Rassismus, keine Politik. Die anderen beiden Sachen finde ich jetzt erst mal komplett ehrbar. Da habe ich nichts dagegen. Gegen keinen Rassismus habe ich auch überhaupt nichts.
Das Thema keine Politik ist natürlich – Es konterkariert vielleicht ein Teil dessen, was man zuerst gesagt hat.
Genau. Und ja, zielt sicherlich darauf ab, einfach irgendwie politische Diskussionen rechts, links, Anschuldigungen nenne ich es jetzt mal, du hast es gesagt, was da gegen St. Pauli auch teilweise zu sehen war, das einfach so ein bisschen rauszuhalten. Aber also richtig verstanden habe ich es auch nicht, weil einfach der Fußball und Fußballfans und das ganze Business natürlich auch extrem öffentlichkeitswirksam ist und extrem politisch in sehr vielen Feldern belastet ist. Oder ich weiß nicht, da fehlt mir gerade das richtige Wort, betroffen vielleicht. Insofern, ich habe es wirklich nicht verstanden, was man damit zusammenbringen wollte.
Und wie groß ist das Problem rechter Fans, die man hat?
Naja, das ist jetzt schwierig einzuschätzen. Also tatsächlich jetzt auch für mich als Fan. Weil ich auch sagen würde, es gab mal, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, dass ein hoher NPD-Funktionär aus dem Stadion geflogen ist, weil Fans ihm signalisiert haben, dass sie ihn hier nicht dabei haben möchten. Du hast auch relativ bekannte Musikgruppierungen, wie Feine Sahne Fischfilet, die jetzt keiner irgendwie in die Nähe von Nazis rücken würde, vermute ich. Die zum FC Hansa gehen, die dort regelmäßig zu sehen sind. So viele meiner Freunde würde ich jetzt auch als eher Links einsortieren. Und trotzdem kann man natürlich nicht wegdiskutieren, dass es da sehr viel rechte Symbolik gibt, dass da auch offensichtlich der Nazis hingehen. Und ja, da gab es auch einen Konflikt, jetzt schon zwei, drei oder wahrscheinlich eher drei, vier Jahre durch Corona her, so die Süd-Tribüne als Stimmungsblock im Ostseestadion. Und da waren jetzt zehn Jahre lang alle Support-Filligen, sag ich mal, zu Hause. Und da ist ein Teil dann ausgezogen, ist auf die Nordtribüne gezogen. Und da sollen wohl auch Differenzen bei der politischen Ausrichtung eine Rolle gespielt haben. Andererseits, ja, wenn man das jetzt gegen St. Pauli gesehen hat, wie da eben sich Teile des Blogs präsentiert haben. Das waren sicherlich Leute aus beiden Blöcken, die da auch irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt haben. Deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen, Hansa ist kein Nazi-Verein. Aber man könnte sicherlich vorsichtig formuliert mehr tun, um diesem Bild in der Öffentlichkeit auch noch mehr entgegenzuwirken.
Und fällt mir das jetzt mehr auf, weil Hansa Rostock in der 2. Liga jetzt wieder ist und dann mehr darüber berichtet wird? Oder gab es da auch eine Entwicklung? Weil wir müssen ja nicht so tun, als ob das jetzt die einzigen Nazis wären, die irgendwo in Fußballstadien sind. Nee, das ist eher so tendenziell, finde ich, eine zunehmende Entwicklung, dass sich Rechte, die oft jetzt anders aussehen, anders sprechen und sich auch vor allem anders organisieren, sich wieder so reingesnickt haben in viele, in viele Stadien. Also da muss man jetzt gar nicht irgendwie extrem Beispiel Cottbus, sondern da kannst du auch zu Borussia Dortmund gucken, da kannst du auch hier beim FC Bayern gucken. Also überall hat man einfach so, wie wir in unserer Gesellschaft ja immer mehr eine Radikalisierung auch wahrnehmen und ja auch ein zunehmendes Antisemitismus. Ich habe heute gelesen, in München gab es im letzten Jahr 178 antisemitische Straftaten, also an jedem zweiten Tag eine im Jahr. Das ist einfach unfassbar, auf was wir uns da wieder zubewegen. Also ich möchte damit eben nicht sagen, nur Rostock und da ist es schlimm, aber es ist mir jetzt eben auch bei Rostock wieder besonders aufgefallen. Liegt das an der Aufmerksamkeit, die ich jetzt mehr habe, für Rostock und vielleicht auch manches Medium, weil es halt ein Zweitligist ist, oder gibt es da auch eine Entwicklung deiner Meinung nach?
Nee, ich glaube da gibt es schon eine Entwicklung, genau wie du es gesagt hast, gesamtgesellschaftlich und im gesamten Fußball, aber sicherlich und auch besonders beim FC Hansa ist da vieles wieder salonfähiger geworden, was es für vor 8 oder 10 Jahren vielleicht noch nicht war, wo man da sicherlich schon mal einen Schritt weiter war, wo ich jetzt auch das Gefühl habe und auch immer wieder Situationen tatsächlich im Stadion erlebe, wo ich denke, das wäre mir wahrscheinlich vor einer Weile nicht passiert, wo es jetzt auch wieder offensichtlicher zur Schau gestellt wird. Und da würde ich dir schon zustimmen bei deiner Einschätzung. Und das liegt nicht daran, dass Hans jetzt wieder 2. Bundesliga spielt, sondern, ja, das ist tatsächlich, denke ich, wer in der 3. Liga oder war auch teilweise in der 3. Liga, für mich schon genauso zu beobachten. Aber ja, da ist es dann vielleicht dir oder vielen anderen Fußballinteressierten ein bisschen verborgen geblieben, weil es dann doch nur in der 3.
Darf ich kurz eine Zwischenfrage stellen? Ich habe es auch immer wieder durch diverse Leute bei mir in der Timeline, die eben, ja, nicht nur die Fans, sich von den Fans distanzieren, die eben für sowas verantwortlich sind, sondern die auch ganz klar die Vereinführung kritisieren für, ja, im Prinzip was, also ich meine, das Video, über was wir gesprochen haben, oder über was ihr gesprochen habt, ist irgendwie so ein bisschen der negative Höhepunkt, aber es gab ja zu den Vorfällen auf St. Pauli, gab es ja Statements vom Verein, wo glaube ich gerade das erste irgendwie einen Zitat aus dem, wie man das auch nennen möchte, ich glaube aus der Vereinssatzung hat, irgendwie der FC Hansa ist nicht politisch so, dass dann irgendwie als Zitat aufgearbeitet wurde, dass das ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht sein kann, dass da irgendwie Rechte oder eine lichten Hagen irgendwie auch missbraucht wurde für, keine Ahnung, für Rechte, um sich gegen St. Pauli zu positionieren. Glaubst du, dass da einfach von der Vereinsführung vielleicht auch mehr kommen muss und dass deshalb vielleicht auch da zum Beispiel von mehr Fans halt der Fokus auch drauf ist, weil man dann irgendwie vom Verein dann einfach vielleicht als eben nicht Hansa-Fan, sondern als anderer auch eben zu wenig einen Widerspruch merkt?
Definitiv ja. Das plus der Punkt, wie formuliere ich das jetzt? Dass die Leute, sage ich mal, die zur Mitgliederversammlung in großer Zahl gehen, das ist nicht unbedingt die Mehrheitsmeinung im Verein. Das ist aber eben eine sehr lautstarke Gruppe und auch gut organisiert, so die dann entsprechend auch die Mitgliederversammlung beeinflussen kann. Und da sind jetzt, denke ich, viele Leute dabei, die für Dinge, die du gerade angesprochen hast, in irgendeiner Weise stehen oder die zumindest tolerieren, die da eben so ein bisschen die Stimmung vorgeben, so dass es da aktuell schwierig ist, für uns andere Mitglieder dagegen laut zu werden. Da fehlt auch ein bisschen der Organisationsgrad. Ich glaube, dass sich auch die Vereinsführung da ein bisschen versteckt oder das deutlich offensiver angehen könnte, aber da auch Angst vor dem internen Gegenwind hat und das deswegen nicht macht, so würde ich es mal formulieren.
Es ist halt schade. Es ist schwierig, darüber zu sprechen, weil Wittenberg ist nicht Paris. Ich stehe hier in München und kann dann sagen, Mensch, ihr müsst doch einfach keinen Fuß breiten den Faschisten und so weiter, weil ich es so auch denke, aber dann selbst in der Situation zu sein und entsprechend zu handeln ist schwierig. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch wahrscheinlich für dich eine schwierige Situation. Mir ist es unter anderem bewusst geworden, als ich mal mit Vereinsverantwortlichen von Dynamo Dresden gesprochen habe, wo ich auch eine sehr klare Meinung zu sehr vielen Sachen hatte, die Dresden-Fans getan und gesagt und gesungen und gebannert haben. Und da fand ich ganz viel davon einfach menschenverachtend und habe mir da auch ein entschiedeneres Vorgehen dagegen gewünscht. Und dann sprichst du mit Vereinsverantwortlichen. Also Dresden ist jetzt nicht Rostock, bei Rostock weiß ich nicht, wie es ist. Aber Dresden ist ja sogar dazu übergegangen, irgendwann eine Internetseite einzurichten, wo sie einfach nur alle Maßnahmen, die sie machen, von Info-Arten bis hin zu Soziale Arbeit usw. gegen Nazis, gegen Rassismus und Diskriminierung jeder Art auflisten, um zu sagen, wir versuchen es wirklich, aber wir haben einfach immer noch ein Problem mit solchen Fans. Und das ist ja auch für dich schwierig. Du bist Fan dieses Vereins, wir alle haben uns unseren Fußballverein nicht ausgesucht. Du weißt doch, dass es genügend andere Fans auch noch gibt. Du hast ja auch unter anderem ein paar Prominente schon genannt. Und trotzdem ist es eben ein Problem und es ist vielleicht sichtbarer als bei anderen Vereinen. Ich meine, die Bilder, die man da von der St. Pauli-Auswärtsfahrt gesehen hat, das ist schon einfach sehr eindeutig. Und wenn da dann auch irgendwelche verurteilten Nazis in der ersten Reihe stehen und man die identifizieren kann, da will ja auch niemand gegenandiskutieren. Und trotzdem stelle ich mir das jetzt einfach für dich ganz persönlich. Es ist eine sau-schwierige Situation, oder?
Definitiv. Wobei ich bei dem Thema verurteilte Nazis dachte, also ich möchte mit dem nichts zu tun haben. Das möchte ich ganz klarstellen. Aber da muss ich eben auch sagen, es ist 30 Jahre her, er ist verurteilt worden, hat aber dann auch seine Strafe irgendwo verbüßt. Das ist nicht, wie gesagt, ich kenne ihn nicht, ich möchte ihn jetzt nicht gutreden, aber das ist so ein Gedanke, der mir da durch den Kopf ging.
Ja, stimmt, hast du natürlich recht. Eigentlich sollten wir als Gesellschaft, man hat eine Haft auch dafür, dass man dann danach sagt, okay, jetzt bist du wieder integriert in die Gesellschaft, ja.
Ja, in der Theorie ja, aber da, wo er dann halt gestanden hat, vor dem lichten Hagenbanner, wofür er ja, glaube ich, verurteilt wurde, das ist halt der Kontext dann, wo man dann halt, glaube ich, in dem Fall da vielleicht ein bisschen anders argumentiert hat.
Sehe ich ja absolut in dem konkreten Fall auch so, war bloß ein Gedanke, der mir eben durch den Kopf geht, dass man eben sagt, okay, Straftäter irgendwie haben sie ihre Tat auch verbüßt und dürfen dann auch wieder zum Fußball fahren, so scheiße, wie man das finden kann. Zu dem Lichtenhagen-Banner, da muss ich vielleicht auch noch was sagen oder möchte ich was sagen. Ich meine, außerhalb von Rostock, würde ich jetzt behaupten, kennt man ja Lichtenhagen nur durch diese rassistischen Vorfälle 1992. So in Rostock ist das natürlich ein bisschen anders. Also ich bin jetzt kein gebürtiger Rostocker, aber meine Großeltern waren da, ich habe da einen Teil meiner Jugend verbracht und so weiter, würde sagen, dass ich mich in Rostock ganz gut auskenne. So und das ist einfach diese Sonnenblumenhäuser. Es gibt ja nicht nur eins. Die sind natürlich einfach das Kennzeichen für diesen Stadtteil. Und zumindestens mir geht es so, wenn ich in Rostock unterwegs bin mit der S-Bahn, vom Stadtzentrum nach Warnemünde, da gibt es verschiedene Neubaugebiete, die man beim Blick aus dem Fenster an irgendwas erkennt. So bei einem Lüttenglein ist es der Igerpark, beim anderen Lichtenhagen sind es eben die Sonnenblumenhäuser. Und auch da wohnen meines Wissens ganz normal Leute drin, auch nicht wenige, sondern in dem ganzen Plattenbaugebiet wohnen ein paar tausend Leute. Und deswegen finde ich es erstmal nicht verwerflich, muss ich sagen, dass es dieses Banner gibt. Also das wurde ja, habe ich teilweise in Diskussionen schon gelesen, ja wie kann man überhaupt so ein Banner produzieren? Da würde ich jetzt einfach erstmal sagen, es würde Leuten zugestehen, die da wohnen, die ihren Stadtteil mögen, dass sie sich eine Fahne malen, wo ihr Stadtteil drauf steht. So, das zweite ist aber natürlich, wie das eingesetzt wird. Das ist aus meiner Sicht eine absolute Katastrophe. Und noch viel schlimmer ist, dass es eben zweimal jetzt in dieser Saison passiert ist. Und eben, dass es dann gut sichtbar Richtung der St. Pauli-Fans hängt, dass eben da bestimmte Leute auch noch direkt sichtbar dahinterstehen, dass dann wie im Gästeblog in St. Pauli da überall noch Sonnenblumen aufgehängt werden. Ja, und dann eben um die maximale Provokation sozusagen auf dem Rücken von Opfern rassistischer Gewalt zu erzielen. Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich so das Hauptproblem, dass man als Hansa-Fan, unabhängig von der politischen Einstellung, also dass es Gruppen bei Hansa gibt, die einfach extrem auffallen wollen und extrem provozieren wollen. Und dass dazu eben gefühlt jedes Mittel recht ist. Und das ist auch schon eine ganze Weile so, dass gefühlt bei jedem Auswärtsspiel die Klos zerstört werden. Also es müssen Leute irgendwie rumlaufen und die ganze Woche denken, geil, am Wochenende fahre ich nach Groß-Aßbach oder nach Wiesbaden oder zum Hamburger SV und kann endlich wieder Toiletten zerlatschen. So was mir wirklich nicht in den Kopf will, aber offenbar gibt es solche Leute. Und dann will man eben da auch gerade dadurch, dass man glaube ich lange nicht in der deutschen oder so im Fokusstand im deutschen Fußball dadurch auffallend, dass man einfach extrem ist. Und ja, das merkt man eben auch am Verhalten so. Ich möchte noch mal sagen, diese Provokation, das lehne ich absolut ab, das ist eine absolute Katastrophe und glaube aber, dass das einfach so das Interesse vieler ist, maximal zu provozieren, egal womit am Ende. Hauptsache man findet irgendwas, womit man dem Gegner richtig doll auf die Nerven gehen kann.
Männliche Fußballfans, man muss sie einfach lieben. Und ich glaube, man kann es auch wieder aus Geschlecht runterbrechen. Zumindest, na wobei, wer weiß ja, ob da einzelne Frauen mit dabei sind. Aber das Verhalten ist dann doch ein eher männlich kodiertes. Ich glaube, so können wir es stehen lassen, auch wenn ich noch keine Toilette ausmache.
Naja, ein anderer Punkt, der bei uns ja, also der gegen Hansa regelmäßig hervorgekrampft wird, ist ja Plakate, die tatsächlich existieren. Wo drauf steht, hier kein Instagram, kein YouTube, bla bla bla, und keine Frauen in den ersten drei Reihen. Also das ist ja, ist jetzt tatsächlich keine Erfindung, die gibt es tatsächlich. Und insofern können wir da schon sagen, dann sind das sicherlich die Männer in den ersten drei Reihen, ja. Oder vier oder fünf leider.
Aber absolut. Aber ich fand's jetzt wichtig, da auch nochmal drüber zu reden. Und es ist, glaube ich, nämlich vor allem auch wichtig, anlasslos drüber zu reden. Also eben nicht, wenn der große Aufreger passiert, den es eben dann gibt. Und der ja auch etwas provozieren soll. Du hast das, finde ich, gerade ganz gut erklärt. Da habe ich nämlich dann auch manchmal das Gefühl, also so richtig ich es immer finde, sich gegen Nazis zu positionieren und das auch zu problematisieren. Aber manchmal habe ich dennoch den Eindruck, da reiben sich manche dann doch auch ihre ansonsten immer ausgestreckten Fäustchen und freuen sich, dass genau das nämlich passiert ist. Nämlich, dass sich eben dann die linke Bubble oder eigentlich die normale Bubble sollte es eigentlich sein. Aber es ist dann doch eher die linke Bubble, sich drüber aufregt. Deswegen finde ich es jetzt eben auch wichtig, jetzt einfach mal, wo in Anführungszeichen nichts Konkretes gerade passiert ist, mal drüber zu sprechen. Weil genau das müssen wir ja machen. Wir müssen da hingucken. Und das eben nicht nur in Rostock, sondern ich habe es jetzt hier auch schon mehrfach gesagt, auch noch bei genügend anderen Vereinen. Es gibt da ganz bedenkliche Tendenzen in Deutschland. Da müssen wir uns gegen positionieren. So, das ist jetzt irgendwie der Schluss dieser Sendung, keine Ahnung. Aber ich will da jetzt auch keine lustige Überleitung machen. Ich sage einfach Danke, dass ihr mit mir auf die Liga geblickt habt und auf eure drei Vereine. Und dann wissen wir ja, zumindest im Tabellenkeller wird es definitiv spannend bleiben, so eng, wie das alles beieinander ist. Und wer weiß, ob Lukas sich vielleicht wirklich noch einschalten kann ins Aufstiegsrennen, sollte St. Pauli gegen HSV unentschieden ausgehen. Dann können wir uns davon sicher sein. Lukas, du hast es uns quasi versprochen. Deswegen, wir werden dich an deinen Worten messen. Das hat man vorhin schon so ein bisschen rausgehört. Also dieses Spiel, das ja eh schon an sich schon spannend genug wäre. Es hat jetzt noch einmal auch mal eine überraschende Düsseldorf-Komponente bekommen, möchte ich dazu sagen. Und für die danke ich dir und dafür, dass du hier warst. Ich möchte nochmal euren Podcast empfehlen. Aus dem Exil heißt ja, da bekommt man natürlich noch viel, viel mehr Informationen zur Fortuna. Danke, lieber Lukas, dass du mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk warst. Und dann danke ich Eva-Lotta Bohle, der at eva-bole. Und bei mastodon.social ist sie natürlich auch. Wie schnell ich lerne. Schön, Eva, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Ja, vielen Dank wie immer für die Einladung. Und ich merke mir das jetzt auch, wie man das korrekt sagt, mit dem at mastodon. Das hat schon damals sehr lange gedauert mit Tuta. Ich verspreche dir auch, ich mache das nicht wie Tuta, dass ich immer mittendrin meinen Nutzen habe.
Ja, stimmt, genau, das gab es ja auch noch. Schon wieder ganz, ganz verändert. Aber er wurde ja einfacher auszusprechen. Das ist ja fast so wie bei einem uns beiden bekannten Fürther-Journalisten. Also danke, dass du hier warst. Und ich danke auch Oliver Leiste, der at leisteo auf Twitter. Danke dir, Oli, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Nach deinem Training noch, meine Güte, du musst doch jetzt richtig müde sein.
Also, dass weder das Training noch der Rasenfunk sind das, was diese Woche anstrengend machen, aber auch das wird vorbei gehen. Nee, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein durfte. Hat wieder sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich freue mich, wenn wir das nächste Mal reden, dass dann die sportliche und die Fansituation beim FC Hansa etwas besser ist. Eva, wo wir gerade bei der richtigen Aussprache sind. Ich glaube, ich werde sonst gemaßregelt, wenn ich dir das komplett durchgehen lasse.
Ich versuche, jedes Mal zu merken.
Ich habe eine Tasse zugeschickt bekommen, als ich es falsch gemacht habe. Also, deswegen, man darf falsch machen, dann kriegt man Tassen zugeschickt. Ich habe auch vorhin Paderborn ganz komisch ausgesprochen.
Vielleicht kriege ich da jetzt auch eine Tasse zugeschickt. Ich möchte keine Paderborn-Tasse.
Ja, du kannst es ja auch mal aussprechen.
Wenn du möchtest, organisiere ich dir eine FCM-Tasse.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, ich werde enterbt, wenn das passiert.
Ich habe hier Bielefeldkrug bei mir im Geschirrschrank stehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der hierher gekommen ist.
Und ich wurde auch richtig enttäuscht.
Ja, habe ich wirklich keine Idee. Na gut, also ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, nochmal verbunden mit dem Appell. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter. Sagt den Leuten, dass wir auch regelmäßig Sendungen zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga machen. Und hört natürlich auch unsere anderen Formate zur 1. Männer-Bundesliga, zur Frauen-Bundesliga und zum Internationalen Männerfußball. Also es gibt wirklich viel zu hören im Rasenfunk. Bitte empfehlt uns weiter. Und bitte unterstützt uns auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub erfahrt ihr wie. Und dann hören wir uns hier wieder, wenn ihr mögt, in der nächsten Sendung. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao.